Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
soy Raúl blanco y saludamos a nuestra
enviada especial a Ucrania Catalina
Gómez Ángel quien en este espacio nos
contará los detalles de todo su
cubrimiento en esa nación en conflicto
Catalina un gusto tenerla en ese espacio
de la entrevista de Francia 24 y
empecemos hablando de estos 10 meses de
la guerra hasta el día de hoy Cómo
afecta los cortes de Electricidad
también por cuenta de los bombardeos
rusos y el desgaste de toda la población
y las fuerzas ucranianas en todo este
conflicto
es Es realmente un golpe en la moral a
pesar de que la moral de los ucranianos
Sigue estando alta es es bastante duro
son diez meses en los que parte de la
población especialmente en regiones como
en jerson en el este mucha gente ha
vivido en sótanos en en condiciones
extremadamente duras con falta ya ya
sufrían por falta de Electricidad
problemas de agua e Imagínese lo que es
este golpe de tener a la gran parte del
país sin luz o si la tienen con largos
cortes de de Electricidad esto afecta
especialmente a las personas mayores y a
las y a los niños me contaban por
ejemplo hace pocos días un una familia
en el oeste del país que sufre menos la
guerra que los niños lo único que
querían y que habían escrito en la carta
de Navidad era que querían que se
acabara la guerra porque ellos querían
que la situación volviera también estos
cortes de Electricidad realmente están
afectando Y esa la gente lo sabe el
Moscú y lo sabe el presidente y por eso
continúa haciendo estos ataques claro
Catalina como también denuncian que
Moscú quiere usar este invierno como un
arma de guerra hablemos ahora de la
situación de lucha actual digamos en el
terreno con las tropas nos centramos en
gerson y cómo ha afectado y cómo ha
afectado todo eso también la moral
Esto fue un golpe de moral para
para la razón fue No solamente la única
capital de provincia que fue tomada por
el control de las tropas rusas sino que
lo lo hicieron desde realmente el
comienzo de la invasión allí habían
creado fortificaciones Allí se habían
asentado habían creado Un gobierno local
inclusive llegaron a ser parte de ser
referéndum que logremos recordemos que
hicieron en su momento Así que el haber
retomado esta ciudad después de que la
presión ucraniana hizo que las tropas
rusas retrocedieran Pues fue un golpe de
Gran moral para todo el pueblo ucraniano
después de también de haber recuperado
grandes zonas en la provincia dejar quis
pero lo que viene ahora es ese azote
constante contra la población que se
quedó y que resistió en gersón o que
estaba pensando volver entonces
realmente lo lo que demuestra es que si
bien Rusia no tiene el control Ellos
están dispuestos a destruir y atacar
todas aquellas ciudades que querían
tener Bajo su Control pero que no la
tienen y que no lograron tenerle y que
posiblemente ya no lo van a lograr claro
Catalina estábamos hablando de la
situación en gersono pero digamos que la
guerra también se centra en jarquife
donde se vuelve otra vez más
mayoritariamente en la región del Don
vas Cuál es la situación allí porque
recordemos que usted pudo pues estar en
gran parte de Ucrania en esta última
visita
sí no solamente en esta visita Raúl sino
que realmente durante estos diez meses
creo que France veinticuatro ha hecho un
gran esfuerzo por recorrer el el país
tanto con todos los equipos que hemos
estado allí y lo hemos hecho y es
interesante ver obviamente después dejar
de haber sido no solamente esa segunda
ciudad de de Ucrania que fue realmente
intensamente atacada Durante los
primeros meses de guerra las poblaciones
aledañas como la población sufrió como
fue atacada y como habla vivían en esos
sótanos de los que yo hablaba
anteriormente como la liberación de
estas zonas le quitó presión a harquif
volvió a traer la vida en esta zona pero
también en áreas del norte de la región
de del donbadas especialmente en una
ciudad que es bastante estratégica es la
ciudad del imán en en el que es el
límite entre entre
también la visitábamos hace pocos días y
era impresionante no solamente el el
grado de destrucción de la ciudad los
pocos habitantes que quedan una ciudad
de como cuarenta mil habitantes quedan
seis mil sino el desgaste psicológico
físico de toda esta población que
realmente lo que nos muestra esas
consecuencias de la guerra si bien ellos
se sienten felices de que han vuelto a
recuperar la ciudad y que están
realmente en poder del control de las
tropas ucranianas obviamente
quedan muchos edificios destruidos hay
mucho trabajo por hacer por la
reconstrucción pero no solamente física
sino moral y psicológica de la población
y y bueno lo que viene porque se nos
viene un invierno muy duro Durante los
días que yo estuve en el donbadas
estábamos A menos diez grados
centígrados con mucho viento algunos
lugares no Tienen calefacción y muchos
de ellos siguen viviendo en esos sótanos
porque sus casas Están destruidas
Catalina Cuál es la situación o también
porque en estos últimos días hemos
hablado de la ciudad de Back mood porque
la importancia y por qué esta ciudad
también hemos hecho también un recorrido
como estas ciudades importantes en esta
guerra y bakmuto es una de ellas
se ha concentrado y Es bien interesante
esto Raúl porque en bakú se ha
concentrado la lucha en el don vast
especialmente desde que tomaron esas dos
ciudades de severodonés y lisich en la
provincia de Luján después de miles de
personas murieron tanto de uno como de
otro bando Esto fue sucedió en junio es
una ciudad que cuando uno habla con los
soldados ucranianos dicen que realmente
no es una ciudad estratégica pero los
rusos han apostado tanto por tomar el
control de esta ciudad que ya se les
volvió casi una obsesión a mí me lo
describió un comandante ucraniano como
una apuesta han apostado y han puesto
tantos hombres allí que ahora es parte
de de su orgullo conquistarla pero
posiblemente no lo no lo van a tomar
porque ahí también están muy bien
ubicadas las las tropas ucranianas a
pesar de que es una ciudad que
bombardean todo el tiempo constantemente
sin parar las tropas que están en estas
posiciones o están en trincheras en
lugares estratégicos o están en sótanos
es una situación muy complicada Y eso
también se extiende en todo aquel frente
del Sur del donbas donde estaba la línea
divisoria con la la que llamaron en su
momento del 2014 esa República
independiente del donest calles habían
unos frentes de batalla muy establecidos
desde ese año y Que obviamente empezaron
a moverse desde la invasión el 24 de
febrero Pero más en estas últimas
semanas donde realmente ese toda esa
batalla todo ese poderío de las fuerzas
rusas y realmente las tienen porque no
logran avanzar tanto están centradas
allí Así que
seguirá siendo el centro y obviamente lo
estamos viendo expandido por toda esa
línea del Don vas donde se seguirá
viendo la guerra de mayor intensidad
Catalina estabas hablando digamos
también de estos territorios donde las
tropas rusas todavía tienen su
influencia y al principio de nuestra
conversación también lo estábamos
hablando estos territorios estos cuatro
territorios ucranianos que Rusia se
anexionó ilegalmente por medio de estos
referendos que no tienen ningún tipo de
reconocimiento digamos ni dentro de
Ucrania ni de la comunidad internacional
Cuál es la situación de estas regiones
de Catalina
Pues bueno ellos y luego lo han vuelto a
repetir en días atrás de que uno de los
grandes objetivos que Rusia no pierde su
gran objetivo de tener en control esas
cuatro provincias de las cuales
tomó este realizó Este referéndum pero
hay que tener bastante claro esto
incluye la la provincia de gerson ellos
ya no tienen el control de la capital de
la provincia tienen control de algunos
sectores donde ahora vemos como las
tropas ucranianas están tratando de
hacer una contraofensiva lo que viene
ahora tal vez en la guerra en Ucrania
esto que vamos a ver ellos ser
contraofensivas en la provincia de
saporilla y en gersón para tratar de
cortar todo el abastecimiento de las
tropas rusas desde desde crimea que eso
será tal vez el Este paso que veamos en
este invierno entonces ahí vienen estos
dos grandes asuntos ni la provincia de
saporilla ni la provincia de gerson ahí
vamos a ver centradas grandes batallas
Incluso en este invierno Raúl donde
mucho se habló de que la que la guerra
se iba a detener por unos meses porque
estaba congelado el piso porque estaba
haciendo extremadamente frío pero lo que
te dicen los comandantes en el terreno
es que la guerra no se va a detener en
invierno incluso ya analistas
especialmente norteamericanos que
hablaron en su momento de que esto no
iba a seguir que esto iba a detenerse
por unos unas semanas han dicho que los
ucranianos están en capacidad de
continuar esta lucha pero también es
interesante ver el nuevo desarrollo
después de esa movilización que a la que
llamó el presidente Vladimir Putin en
septiembre porque lo que te cuentan
también en el en ese frente del Don vas
pero también en saporilla es como esto
ha hecho que los ataques sean con mayor
Infantería y con mayor número de hombres
que son lanzados a la muerte sin ninguna
prevención o sin ninguna consideración
de tener cuidado entre compañeros como
decían los ucranianos para nosotros cada
vida importa para ellos no así que vamos
a ver Tal vez un invierno con unas
batallas muy duras cuando se congela el
piso con un desbalance de hombres pero
también los los ucranianos están usando
toda esta artillería que les ha mandado
occidente y tienen algo que tal vez los
rusos no tienen qué es lo que te dicen
también en el frente y es esa voluntad
de pelear
Catalina ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación usted también ha estado en
estos pueblos alrededor de las ciudades
en las ciudades recuperadas no por parte
de las tropas ucranianas que estaban
ocupadas por los rusos Cómo es la vida
actual en esos pueblos evidentemente
vuelve la población allí pero unos
pueblos totalmente desolados unos unos
territorios en ruinas prácticamente
recuerdos por el piso la moral abajo el
frío del Invierno Catalina dura la
situación no no me quiero imaginar
es es bastante dura porque tenemos la
mayor la mayoría de la población que
vive en esas pequeñas poblaciones que
han sido retomadas son mayores son
personas mayores que no se quisieron ir
porque su casa lo único que tienen
Porque es allí donde tienen su vida
donde se han hecho Entonces como hablaba
es son condiciones extremadamente duras
el gobierno ucraniano y toda la ayuda de
humanitaria trata de llevarles
obviamente alimentos ayudarles a a Si
tienen una casa medio dañada ayudarles
un poco la reconstrucción a llevarles eh
También abrigos pero calefacciones
especialmente para para para usar con
leña pero de todas maneras obviamente
Esto no es fácil especialmente después
de de de con estas temperaturas y el
temor el temor también en muchas
regiones Y eso lo vimos Incluso en el
norte de que es Raúl de que la gente a
pesar de que es optimista no sabe qué va
a pasar en el futuro entonces tienen
miedo también de que vuelvan a cambiar
las fuerzas Entonces todavía hay la
población la incertidumbre Catalina que
también juega en contra en momentos como
estos Catalina se nos acaba el tiempo
para seguir conversando sobre todo lo
que ha sido este cubrimiento especial de
France 24 en estos diez meses que va la
guerra en Ucrania igual un placer como
siempre conversar con usted un abrazo
Catalina
un abrazo Raúl y bueno no sé queremos
conversando y viendo
el Así es Catalina hasta el próximo año
y nosotros de esta manera entonces
finalizamos este espacio de la
entrevista de Francia 24 por esta
oportunidad Hasta pronto
[Música]